professionals understand this goal and
thus direct their energies
self-study and unit development in
particular toward achieving it
so all marines are trying to become
professionals professionals
true experts in the conduct of war
as professionals we recognize that
development of coercive tools must be
balanced with the need to attract
in competition as well for example one
component of an attraction strategy
could lead to greater deterrence through
building
increased interoperability with an ally
it could also lead to advances through
the
informal element of national power as we
perform disaster relief mission
marines must remain alert for the
opportunities to use and integrate both
coercion and attraction into the larger
competition
so the marine corps is not they're
saying here we're not just here to fight
wars
we're here to build relationships now at
echelon front we talk about building
relationships all the time
that's what that's how you lead you lead
by building relationships
that's how you get things done by
building relationships
and what we're talking about here is we
are competing
and in order to compete guess what we do
we build relationships we build
relationships
and just to give people examples and i'm
sure you have some more dave but
especially before the war started
for me in the 90s this is what the seal
teams did
go to a country train their special
operations unit do a big exercise
train them in the use of our weapons we
train in the use of their weapons we
send some people to learn how to speak
their language we bring some people to
learn
that they can learn how to speak english
we form these relationships we work
together
so that way we're strengthening our
allies we have somebody we can rely upon
we get to know them but that's just
relationships that's what it is did you
guys do that in the
in the pilot world yeah i mean i'm
thinking about carrier deployments and i
think right now there's a connotation
that the aircraft carrier and it's
probably already
always existed but certainly now since
you know post 911
the carrier is this power projection
tool this
you know the um uh you know 90 000 tons
of diplomacy you know
sovereign u.s soil all of them they have
these great tag lines the navy
leverages which which are true in a lot
of ways but pre-911 if you ever did a
cruise pre-911 like i did back in the
day
the joke now those we call them pleasure
cruises it was like 13 14 port calls
and the two months you know that you you
sailed from san diego to to the persian
gulf
was a bunch of port calls you're you're
doing joint operations with different
countries you're you're
pulling up pierce out and contributing
to their economy you're building all
those relationships and most of it is
allies or people we want to build
relationships with then you go to the
gulf for a couple months do that thing
and in that you're doing three or four
poor calls to bahrain to the uae all
these places we're trying to strengthen
relationships and that
that to carrier was an instrument of
power projection it was an instrument of
diplomacy
which was building those relationships
obviously post 911
you know my experience my second cruise
was like go to the north arabian gulf
stay there for seven months come home
but you know
before that the investment that navy was
making was mostly strengthening the
relationships and there are stories out
there even somewhat recently that
carriers would deploy for disaster
relief with no aircraft on them just to
send a carrier to help
you know floods and crazy things that
happen in different places
strictly for strengthening ties in
relationships
that are projecting literal no combat
power by design because the navy sea
well i'm sure it's larger than just the
navy but that's my connection and you
know i deployed off carriers for the
most part
so that's attraction right that's that's
that's attraction
as opposed to deterrence right we're
just trying to show people that hey
we're you want to be friends with us
yeah you want to be we're attractive
we can help you if you get into a time
of need we're a good ally at a tactical
level
when i would deploy in the 90s
we would go out and do exercises where i
would be
in the jungle with
some special operations unit from some
other country
what do you do when you are a
fighter pilot same thing are you giving
them a tour
are you taking them in the back seat
like at a tactical level
just out of my own curiosity what would
you do you're
you're flying with them you're spending
time with them and and there's a little
bit wait wait are they flying their
aircraft
and so they're your wingman and you work
so yeah integrating with them sometimes
you fight against them sometimes you
fight with them
really what it's supposed to be is
because you ever put your ego in check
and let one of these
what let one of these foreigners be beat
you in a dog fight
no dude come on man zero percent chance
zero now certain countries
they would have we would fly with
different countries that they would have
different roe
different rules uh training rules and
things like that and you could see some
of them were geared very specifically to
make sure that certain people had
advantages
and we would play by those rules and and
sometimes get in trouble for not
following those rules
uh you know one of the things that's
really cool about the american military
and certainly
in aviation and there's a saying we have
is like hey there's no rank in the
cockpit
so i could be the junior doing the
squadron i'm not saying this happened
very often but you could be a mid-level
guy you're going to go out flight with
your boss
and once you start fighting him like you
can pummel him to just
pummel him into the ground and it's it's
there is no like deference like i don't
want to make the old man look bad you
you go out there and do your thing
um that's not always like that but the
the interaction
in some sense was this idea that this
american military with this big might
this big power our aviation world is is
something they can learn from but we
always learn stuff from them too we
would share briefing techniques and how
they ran their briefs how they trained
their guys how they did certain things
and a lot of it at least on paper was
for us to bring to them
things that could help them get better
but it was always reciprocal we always
learn from operating with other
countries and i flew
with pilots and airplanes from all sorts
of different countries even sometimes
the same exact airplane
but they fly it differently they do
things differently so there's a whole
bunch of things that you can do to
interact with them that is beneficial
for both
it was probably lopsided what we knew
and how we did it was usually more
more beneficial to them but it wasn't
completely one-sided either flying
dissimilar with different countries is a
blast because you learn stuff and go oh
man
we don't do that in our airplanes that's
really good for me to see it makes me
more prepared for
if something actually really happens
would you guys go toe-to-toe top gun
dogfight style one on one yeah you'd
have a you'd have different things
i've never been in a situation where if
the brief was you and me are gonna fight
i don't care what country or what plane
once fights on it is game on there is no
like hey go easy on this guy or let this
guy
i've never been in a dogfight once in my
life other than hey i'm
there to show you certain things but if
it's like a real dog fight like just a
real
fight you're just you fly your best
airplane
there are times that you would dial back
your best jet
because it'd be really it would
undermine
the effectiveness of the training of the
relationship building as well
but it's never to like oh you did you
were eating
good job yeah it really caught me off
guard there yeah yeah you got me
that wasn't happening that would be you
know in in the heyday of can you when
you're
a top gun ip and you're fighting against
you know somebody else and you're gonna
come back
no joke you come back with 25 30 valid
shots
that can be really disheartening for
somebody to look on paper and go hey let
me see your shot card and they've got
zero shots
and you're like oh hang on i need to get
my second sheet of paper
and if there's a top gun ip or a weapon
school ip listen to this they're
laughing right now because
you can come back with in four or five
sets five six shots per and you have
30 valid shots and the other guys got
zero if you do that set
after set after set after set after a
while it'd be like you and me
rolling on the mats and you doing
nothing but trying to beat me you're not
teaching me you're not training me
you're just going to beat me like
bro what i don't want to do this anymore
so
you would dial that back but you'd never
be like oh dave that was amazing how you
did that i
i didn't think you could you would never
get to that level of that in an actual
fight when we're training and doing
other things yeah
you're there to learn and they they
learn from you learn from them but i've
never been in a 101
1v1 where i'm dialing it back because
somebody needs you know somebody's
saying hey don't don't fight your best
gem
i'm only doing that you know in a
tactical sense of helping him see sight
pictures and maneuvering in a way that's
benefiting him
uh but not like because i feel bad or
something like that
are the personalities of the foreign
countries
fighter pilots similar to americans
yeah one other thing too i'll be
interested in what you saw with special
forces around the world
what i came to find is despite what
appears to be a whole bunch of
differences between different countries
when it came down to it
the personalities of fighter pilots are
really similar there are differences
there are some cultural things there are
some organizational things but at the
end of the day
fighter pilots that fly fighters in any
country and every type any type of
fighter
they're much more similar than they are
different yeah same thing with
special operations they'd have there's
definitely some some differences in
culture and whatnot but
it's it's a pretty thin pretty thin
layer
that you have to pull back and also oh
these guys are kind of just like us
the mentality yeah totally yeah from a
maintenance perspective
it seems like just the american sort of
from manufacturing to like maintenance
the maintenance programs in the navy you
know
even in the seal teams we would
especially
before the once the war started we kind
of we we
saw less of the navy kind of
administrative stuff right
on our in inside the terms
but when the 90s it was like hey you got
to do these protocols that the big navy
follows and
and so you'd see oh well you know these
guys are squared away the navy
is squared away there's a reason that
when you
when you pull a piece of firefighting
gear off of a
wall on a ship that's been there for
three years
it works it works because it's gone
through this maintenance check it's gone
through every 30 days and every 90 days
it's gotten this it's got this that the
other thing
is are there are do foreign countries
have that same
level of uh being squared away from a
maintenance perspective
you know i don't know i i don't know if
i ever got to that level
that layer of fidelity i will say that
the american military certainly the navy
and the marine corps
i get most of my experience with that is
something we take
really really seriously and what you
just described is
the equipment that we have the things we
have as old as they are whatever the
things that we have
work and that when i manned up an
aircraft
i never once got in an airplane and felt
like kind of sketchy about it
never once did i get an airplane and not
feel like i'm getting an airplane and
i'm not sure
i'm not sure if that's true for for
other countries or other other services
well outside of america but i always and
i've flown with the navy a lot i
followed the marine corps a lot i
followed the air force a lot and that is
universal okay so i have a different
feeling and i have gotten into aircraft
and been completely sketched out with
both my fingers crossed hoping that this
thing is going to make it
and in all those cases it wasn't a it
was an aircraft that was not an american
military aircraft when you're going
well i guess this is we could go down
like that this could be it
i never had the best feeling and what's
weird is
you know the the other thing about the
american military
aircraft is they're working man like the
navy helicopters
they're great they're just they're you
know what they are they're daily drivers
yeah they're a daily driver
a a ch-46 a navy ch-46
that thing is a daily driver that thing
is a ford f-150
that's just ready it's that thing is
going to do its job
so i always felt even though there'd be
hydraulic fluids
all over the deck and it would it would
be a little bit
it would look sketchy but you're you
know that that thing's been flying
well first how old is the ch-46 platform
early 1960s and some of those birds are
from the 1960s
still flying well at least they were
still flying when when
i was in yeah all right little tangent
right there
and what's interesting is everything we
just talked about
all plays that's what this whole book is
about it's about competition but it's
all those things that's the reason i was
kind of diving into it it's all these
things are how we are competing
with our allies and with our rivals and
we're letting everybody know that this
is what we've gotten these are
capabilities and this is what we can do
like that's all part of the game yeah
and i was thinking that
that that tangent was also like that's
what makes us professionals that's the
profession of what we're doing
it's not a it's not a it's not a hobby
it's fun as it is it's it's
flying airplanes all those are
professional things and that's
when we were uh working with other
countries
the one thing i will say this is that i
know when you were going to fight
someone outside of your squadron
so another squadron and then outside of
the service like we're gonna go with the
air force
you you had the sense of like you gotta
you gotta be on your a-game when we were
fighting with other countries
it was like you you are gonna show them
your absolute
best game in everything we do from brief
to shut down and everything in between
so there was a sense of looking the part
and that ev
every step away from your squadron from
your bros that went up higher like don't
you go fight with the air force and
embarrass us
and when you're fighting you know
working with foreign countries the need
to look professional was absolutely
understood
verbalized at all or no absolutely
absolutely absolutely
check who would you train with like for
example like what what other country
let me i mean okay so i have trained
personally with
canadians australians brits saudis
emiratis kuwaitis singapore
malaysia i'm i'm running out there's
more these are all just air forces or
services
your countries that fly different
airplanes or interacted in some way
um japan a whole bunch of countries
do you ever fly their planes so every
you said something i'm kind of laughing
at it and i didn't know we're going to
circle back to it
every single time you go do this kind of
the last day or two you have some
graduation thing and they're always
offering
hey you jumping and i remember i flew
single-seat airplanes so
it wasn't always that we could do that
but if there's a two-seat jet or
something we always offering and they're
always offering us hey jump in the back
seat
i never once never once i don't want to
be in the back seat
first of all of anything certainly not
of a you know a former
soviet union mig-29 that's you know
wow i never got in the backseat of
somebody else's airplane you were busy
couldn't do it that day not available um
and that i think is what you were saying
like
i don't know anything about any of these
i don't know about this airplane and
first of all i don't want anything in
the back seat
i don't know if the cool and guys would
guys would kill for that stuff
and i never wanted to do it but you know
back of a flanker or a mig or something
go for it dude that's all you yeah
sometimes you'd have the same planes
though right or no
yeah canadians australians look for the
exact same airplanes
it's the like in the seal teams if
you're going to do something in some
foreign aircraft
the only way to get out of it would be
to basically
quit you know you can't say like well
hey guys i'm not really comfortable with
this aircraft
and so you're sitting there in a squad
and every single one of those probably
like there's
every single one of those guys is
thinking we should not be doing this
and every single one of those guys
doesn't say a word about it gets on that
bird
and goes and does what you got to do not
me